hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Monster Hunter again
we're just gonna do a really quick video
on how to get the Mega Man outfit now
it's a really cool outfit for your
pellicle and basically you're gonna be
wanting to do the quest a rush of blood
it is a star seven quest which requires
HR 13 and you're gonna be needing to
fight to Oda Garen's one small and one
large one now originally a lot of people
thought that you were supposed to
basically be have a ps4 and only to do
this but as it turns out I have an Xbox
and I was able to do this quest so that
is possible for all console players of
course which is really nice to hear
afterwards once you beat these guys you
will get what's called a Megaman ticket
once you get three of them you could
take it to the smithy and you will get
the full set under the Forge palico
equipment in the full armor sets tab now
that there really isn't much it is just
an armor set there is no weapon my
weapon was the exact same it's the one
that you get for fighting xeno so I have
that weapon equipped but in terms of the
armor it has 351 defence and six
resistance all across the board for
everything so it's honestly not that bad
it's not that great either though cuz
there is some better options which you
can obviously min/max for a fire damage
if you need it or any of that type of
stuff but it's a good all-around base
one and it really isn't that hard to do
just thought I'd let you guys know on
this really quick event quest I'm gonna
let the rest of the quest play out while
I beat the [ __ ] out of the little out of
the to order Garren's and that's just
gonna be about it guys hopefully you
guys didn't enjoy though I liked the
video if you did enjoy me just help me
out I got I got of course I've been
posting lots of Monster Hunter content
you could check out my other video such
as solo guides how to get the Pookie
outfit all that good stuff in the spring
blossoms event as always subscribe if
you're new I cover a lot of months 400
videos like I've said solo guides and
the Pookie outfit and all the other type
of [ __ ] that I have for the event quests
my two most recent videos are going to
be on screen at the end of this once I
beat them but with that guys hope you
have a great yesterday and peace out and
enjoy that Megaman outfit
[Music]